Well, there are a few things we need to
do. We need to clean up Puffer C++.
Um, the new C++ backend just needs to be
cleaned up.
We need to get a heck of a lot more for
the profiler.
some optimizations. I'd be happy just
like knowing how fast everything is by
the end of today, not really doing any
hard optimization work.
I think we'll start with that as the
high level plan.
I'd also like to have more m bound to
puffer so we can play with them.
We will uh we'll start checking. I'm
very very tired today. So, um
I think what I'm going to try to do is
like just with Claude go through all the
stuff that's basically
uh just pure template matching and then
intentionally not try to do the stuff
that is more than that because I'm going
to be too tired and I'm going to like,
you know, I'm not going to do that
correctly today. Um
yeah,
we'll do that.
So, let's get this set up.
do this.
Okay.
Man, that's still so nice to look at
that this is actually real.
just seeing that number.
Hey, Liberty.
I am I am super freaking tired today.
So, I'm going to get done what I can.
It's mostly going to be cleaning up and
profiling work for um
well, since we hit the the speed target
at least.
So yesterday
I ran Yesterday was my birthday. So I
figured for 29 I was going to run a PR
three mile. I did a 20 minute three mile
flat on the treadmill. Um
I trained with
I got a training session with a
ridiculously good powerlifter and I'm
now completely sore and uh and then my
family surprised me with a bunch of
alcohol. So that was uh probably not the
best for recovery.
for a better thumbnail.
What the hell's the thumbnail?
Isn't it the Neural MMO channel one?
we'll eventually probably switch that to
just be the puffer if I haven't
I'm getting the puffer redesigned.
Thanks, Shadows. Uh, and Liberty. Yeah,
eventually we're I actually need to find
a good character artist for the the
puffer because uh I want to get I I
don't really want it to look all that
different. I kind of just wanted to get
it like the model redone in a way that
it's easier to do rigs for. Um because
I'm going to want like a nice animation
set. It's your pick. Hello.
Why is it?
What's the thumbnail?
Did I have it as my profile picture?
Oh, it is.
Ask a nano for a better thumbnail. Then
what? [laughter]
All right. So
yeah, unfortunately I'm a little out of
it today um from the celebrations, but
I think we can still get some basic
stuff in here. Yeah. Like all right,
this is this is what I'm thinking today.
So we have this endbinding.h
and then we have where's the breakout C?
Yeah. So we have these like little
binding files right and then what
happens at the moment
uh they get compiled with this backend
interface
and then they get compiled to have the
multi-threaded C back end for them.
I think we want to have some better
performance testing on this.
Oh yeah. Um, also before I do this, we
had a contributor send to me
Peru, right? So, Peru was sent me a
thing and I don't understand what he
sent me.
Okay, so let me see what the heck this
is.
See if I can understand this.
lib torch plus streams plus threads to
sublinearly scale
eval train loop.
multi-threaded GPU batches each with its
own food stream.
This is how I've done it as well.
Fused kernels with out tensors.
Okay, I used this for him already from
him already.
No tensor Alex
during the forward pass. This is
interesting.
This actually is probably something we
can look into.
Each horizon runs H segment
sequentially.
Each segment runs n environments.
I don't think this is anything different
from what I have.
Transferring ops to GPU. Running forward
pass. Horizon
must run the segment sequentially.
Batches can be run in parallel.
Parallelize the copy plus ops using the
same multi-threaded input from the
previous optimization.
Each batch of B environments
copies to the GPU all by running forward
pass and scheduling to be run using fire
thread. Yeah. So this is what we have as
well.
I'm gonna have to talk to him about what
he has done differently here because
I think
Oh,
this one. I like this. I need to do this
as well.
once I get my I'm going to chat with him
a bit, but once I um what can I share
this? It's just our It's right here.
I'll put the link. So, this is perused
stuff. Um, I think that what I'll do is
once I have uh our basic version of this
out, maybe I'll just put some bounties
on optimizations
because I frankly with this I can't tell
how much of this is stuff I haven't
I I found that you get a lot out of
cudigraphs actually.
Oh, wait, wait, wait. What's this?
I need this.
Wait, what?
Oh, this is this is um
this has got to be flawed or something,
right? Like what what the hell is this
writing?
already committed our available US
dollars to Nvidia. What
Let me go see because I actually want
that.
That actually is one of the things I was
looking for how to do.
That was one of the things I could not
find.
What architecture gets a lot of cuda
graphs?
Just the fact that you have a bunch of
ops in general. So
what you have to do is you fuse as much
as possible and you graph everything
else.
Uh we have 10 mill steps per second
training.
So we hit the number.
Now we mostly need to just benchmark and
clean up stuff like that.
Adam
activation out.
Okay. Well, we'll come back to that. But
like I that's one thing that we'll defin
we're definitely going to use.
Apparently they there is a fused
activation here. Well, I you never know.
I mean, I could go look this thing up
and this could just not be fused,
but this is why we want to go test some
stuff.
Let's figure out the best way to get
everything set up.
set myself up with
a little bit of background music
and we're going to start working on some
stuff.
Yeah, we need this build time to be
faster for sure.
So, we have a heck of a lot of tests
here.
Uh the graph output being this fast is
kind of wonky to me.
It like sometimes helps, sometimes
doesn't.
Why did you choose Mr.
Uh there really not that many choices
for like fast architectures.
I think you're probably
I wanted to try something based on
prefix scan. This was the simplest
option and uh it worked. It matched LSTM
Perf with only one very small
modification.
I will say I dramatically underestimated
the amount of work it was going to be to
actually get a reasonable kernel for it
though. You actually just have to fuse
everything to make it fast.
But I think more generally
like mining versus some other slightly
different gate structure that will be
very easy to change. The question is
just going to be longer term, you know,
is it going to be a prefix scan based
architecture or not, right?
I personally
I could see it being something else
maybe, but prefix scan is really really
good.
I would think you would combine prefix
scan with like some other thing. Um
maybe like some other output or some
like something. But like the prefix scan
itself is so so good.
Like you fully parallelize all your
mles.
grab some 10 mil.
Now, just today we're going to we really
just want to understand um like start
getting all our profiling code into
place. I figured the last little bit of
PF is going to just be much easier with
better profiling tools. So, we're gonna
just chill and
do some work on that today.
I'm like super super tired today. So,
we're going to just do um some lighter
stuff.
And also, everything is sore.
Yeah, I need to I still need to do this,
Jess. I still need to do that.
I don't think I could even I honestly
don't even think I can properly review
like a new environment by hand right now
um for Raph. So, I had yesterday I did
like some crazy workout for my birthday.
I had a couple important meetings and
then my uh my family surprised me with
some celebrations that included a
ungodly amount of alcohol. So, um yeah,
I'm a little out of it.
It was fun though.
But I figure that I have a fair bit of
work to do that's just like
it's essentially applying like simple
fixed transformations to the codebase to
get it into better shape. And uh I can
do most of that with claude without
having it destroy what I've set up. Um,
I wouldn't even want to do the more
complicated stuff today because I'll I
won't be able to think about it clearly
enough. But I figure if we can just get
some good profiling on all the kernels
on the forward and backward passes
overall and on the uh the environment
vectorization with some nice scaling
that would be good.
But we can also just do like test
correctness, right?
Args out
state.
Ah,
okay.
I'm very proud of the uh the 20 minute
3mile though from yesterday. So 29 and I
just I pretty much just smoked all of my
um like short slashmedium distance I
guess whatever you call that distance uh
times
640 pace for three miles.
my best um in high school when I was in
shape for squash. So I weighed 135 lbs.
Like I I 40 I weigh at least 40 lbs more
now, right? Um my best two-mile time
back then on a track was uh 14 minutes.
So 27 minute miles. I just did three
miles in 640 pace. Very very happy with
that, but I'm very smart.
5 mil frog environment.
think you'd make a terminal.
[laughter]
That's funny.
Hey man, like if it's a cool M, like we
can add some stuff, right?
We also have the um there's like the
robe cross again,
another Atari one.
Wait, Scratch got it six. Not looping.
What?
15080.
You get six. Did you get six mil on
puffer um on puffer three or on puffer
four?
I I've only ever seen like above 5 mil
and puffer three if you use really like
large batches. So the perf target for
puffer 4 um
it's two buffers 8192 m so 4096 per
forward pass and then 32k mini batch for
training.
If I set it higher then puffer will be
much faster.
like how it's done this.
See, this is where I have to like
I essentially have to be careful.
What's happening here?
Chill stream. I'm basically just like
cleaning up uh some of our profiling.
I already have these numerical tests
written in Python. So, I'm just using um
Opus to like help port them over to T
torch. And then I'm kind of just making
sure it doesn't make a mess of it. And
then after this, we're going to add uh
we're probably going to port over some
of the tests we have for our environment
vectorization.
And then that's going to run uh we're
going to get correctness and performance
tests on that.
Oh, in general, Spartan, this is high
performance reinforcement learning
development. So I have the fastest
reinforcement learning library and I
stream all of my development on it.
at the moment. We're doing just um we
hit the uh the target uh the target
speed for the next release last frame.
And now I am just like going through and
cleaning up some profiling code thinking
how to fix calculations of advantage
without having to do another step. be
thrown away but with some approximation
calculation I don't know
um if you're talking about the rerunning
of that puffer kernel uh I think we can
just use the like that kernel can be
made faster and it's already not that
much overhead actually the thing that's
a lot of overhead is the indexing ops
the way that we have our train loop
structured but I wouldn't worry about it
too much because like I know for sure
that chunk of code in the whole way that
we do stuff there is going to change a
lot in Puffer 5 because we have some
algorithm plans.
Let me get rid of this bot.
Stupid.
All right.
This will be fine.
I do not like how um verbose this crap
is.
We'll keep this one for now and then we
will we're going to edit this. So
basically I'm going to iterate on this a
whole bunch.
Um so this is clean
semianually before we have it apply this
to all of them.
Loop starts at BPT minus Wait, the loop
starts at BPT minus 2 because it needs
current,
you always waste one step, right?
Because you always want like next value.
So you either have to collect a buffer
and then throw away the last step in the
loss, which is what we do now, or you'd
have to do an extra value at the end.
test
made a mess.
There's a reason I just like imagine if
I just said, "Okay, yeah, cool. Now do
this for all of Like look at this is
like so bloated and messy.
Last one to always be zero.
But you just don't train on it. Like you
can just not train on it then. Antonio,
right?
Well, let's get it how I want it first
and then we'll see how it can be cleaned
up.
so kind of we need to profile the
vectorzation and that's going to be the
big thing at the moment. You should be
able to make your MS very very fast
actually. um the raw sim speed single
thread should very rarely be the
bottleneck if you're writing reasonable
code
to a bunch of other stuff. This is why
this is why we need all this profiling
because I plan to write a very nice
article on this
Verbose logger.
More detailed breakdown.
Yeah, Jeff, we have several of those.
So, we have um we have a profile tag on
Puffer that lets you profile blocks. So,
you get block level profiling.
There's um an NSIS script where you can
get kernel level profiling, you can get
graph level profiling
during training, and then there's this
script which is standalone kernel
profiling.
There's quite a bit of stuff that we
have to add and I got to figure out like
what needs to be here and what doesn't.
I actually what I'd like to have is I
think we're going to get this CSV into
um we're probably going to get like a
CSV that goes on the puffer site or
whatever so we can see the current
timings.
Yeah,
this is what I'm working on at the
moment. It's like we really really need
good profiling and it's it's very
tempting to like just sort of skim over
it, but it's it's very important that
this be done well. Yeah. For puffer 4,
for puffer 3, you have block level
profiling and you have the uh the
built-in torch profiler. We've gone way
way way deeper than that for puffer
dress sanitizer different piece per
Yeah, there is some perf stuff just so
like in puffer 3 we have region based
stuff.
Um it this is where like if you look at
the dashboard the percentage numbers
they're region based tags
that give you the breakdown of that and
then you can also run there is a bind
for the torch profiler that will give
you more accurate breakdown of stuff. Um
but really it's what we have here is way
way way better anyways like this will be
the thing that goes in next.
I'm trying to think if I really want to
have this
like it makes sense to have because
we're doing it with the torch reference.
It makes sense to have it checked via
torch.
Yeah, I'm just going to kind of like
slowly think about how I want these
checks to be implemented.
Uh well then once I have them correct,
it'll be very quick to just have this
thing apply to all the kernels.
Yeah. See, so that's going to be way
cleaner.
See, I want to do everything at the CUDA
level when I can, like not with the
torch wrapper level. But when you're
doing numeric checks versus torch,
you kind of want to profile the whole
thing or kind of want to check the whole
thing.
did put it somewhere stupid though. Hang
on.
16 now.
and
Um, go beat whatever whatever athletic
accomplishments you've had from when you
were younger. Just go beat those and
then you won't feel old.
It's that easy.
Okay, this is a little bit better.
Here's the restroom real quick. Stomach
is still not great. And um I will come
back. I got to think about this profile
a little bit more and then we'll apply
it to everything. We'll do the full
path.
Give me a few minutes.
I came up with a whole bunch of
additional things I want to do with the
profiler today.
[snorts]
A whole bunch of additional things.
No, I basically I just want to see like
all our different profiling options.
What? Well, let me see if this even the
tool that we care about.
Let's see if that's even the tool we
care about.
I don't know if we need this or we just
use NSS
So, we definitely want to get this to
play with
Can I actually just try this on my host
real quick?
Let me see real quick if I can just do
this.
Does not have Okay, so even not in the
containers. This is some [ __ ]
Okay. So, um
that's really obnoxious.
Yeah, that did not work.
That's uh very very annoying.
I do not understand how is it like
installed as a user. All right.
Like I don't know how this is not
installed systemwide.
What? I'm just trying to figure
something stupid out.
Okay, that runs. Okay, this is it.
I just want to see what this thing gives
us.
Okay, what does this give us? Let's see.
This gives us way too much information
to be useful.
Yeah, this is like too much information
to be remotely useful.
See what we have.
Was this unique info or is this
duplicated?
This is just ridiculous amounts of
information.
I mean this gives us a huge amount of
information
but I think that this is
yeah this is best used for like
optimizing single kernels
what this tool is
I mean this gives you literally
Everything.
about the different tools that we have
here. Okay, so we have
we can use to sync different sections of
the code
if we want to.
It's probably best used for um the user
dashboard.
We have our profile that just tells us
the timings
of various implementations.
We have NSIS
which we're primarily using to figure
out
um
what kernels are active.
We have NCU which is the heavy tool for
optimizing single kernels.
What I basically have to do is look at
all these and figure out if we're going
to make use of all these cleanly
together
that gets us what we
I like the idea. of having every chunk
of the training code um being
independently profiler profilable
there's summary like a specific set of
summary that I'm going to
I also I like having the profile like
the kernel tests themselves being able
to be very fast.
But then you would run MCU on those to
really optimize, right?
Well, no, because MCU gets you
diagnostics.
See, this is where I have to be careful
because I have to design this. I can't
let design this.
can have it help move things around once
I know how it should look. But I have to
figure out how it should look.
There's no um
it's all Python
sources
100% Python.
Okay,
it's fine.
How much of this has to go through
torch?
A lot of it does unfortunately.
I mean, the goal is we don't want to run
in on an entire training, right?
What actually has to change for this to
work?
This little CLI thing is very easy to
add at the bottom.
The problem is that the we have this
gigantic class.
I feel like I'm simultaneously over and
underthinking.
Oh, I missed your message. Two years old
will be hugely different.
Um 100 mil. I didn't say we could hit
100 mil.
100 mil is very difficult on this
current hardware. We said 10 mil for
this update. The algorithms will be
better though in uh in two years.
And no, we don't do unlimited kernel
optimization.
We do start thinking about different
architectures though that are uh more
hardware efficient.
I think 100 mil is like theoretically
possible if you go but like 100 mil
doesn't scale to bigger models. I don't
know if it's worth getting 100 mil for
the really really small models.
Uh it is definitely worth getting 10 mil
though.
Okay. So, I mean really all we need to
do Yes.
I think the thing that's driving me a
little like that's annoying me here is I
can see how we profile all the
individual functions. I'm still trying
to figure out how we profile the overall
training nicely.
Maybe we just do use our profile tool
for it, right?
Maybe that's it. Maybe we don't need to
run NSIS on training.
Okay, so we run NSIS on
the individual ops.
And then we use blocks to profile the
whole thing.
And then possibly we have NCU for kernel
level stuff.
So all we have to do for that is we just
have to move
we just have to move every op into um
yeah we just have to make sure every op
is moved into a function call
and we should be okay.
And then we'll expose to um
the profiler.
This need to be separate from the kernel
profile though
Well, I think I have enough to start on
this though. Let me go grab myself a
nice mug of tea and then we'll um
we will start in earnest on this. I
think I've like figured out some stuff
as to how I want to set up the profiler.
Um
yeah, I think this should be fine. I'm
going just like compact this
then we'll we'll go back because I this
is actually something that I'm going to
be able to use cloud for a bunch because
it's basically
it's a very very simple refactor but
then like a bunch of moving around
profile code. I'll be right back.
I'm starting to think more clearly about
this.
Let's just show
cuz the whole thing is graphed. The
weird chunk
Do I like the idea of having
instance of puffel
[sighs]
man, it's so freaking hard to think
about how the profiler should be
cleaning up. Yeah, FBR. It's it's very
difficult to think about how I should
have the profile structured.
Can you articulate why it's difficult?
Because there's several different levels
of stuff you want to profile
and you want to do it without making
either a huge gigantic amount of
profiling code where everything is
duplicated or making a mess of the
original code. Um you've got kernel
level profiles, you've got function
level profiles, you've got training
level profiles, you've got with and
without pseudograph optimization, you've
got the uh like the native C++ versions.
So a lot to think about.
No way to share the data.
Well, there is. I have to figure it out
though.
So, I'm thinking now if I have the
standalone profile script, right?
Maybe I can have it so that I can call
NSIS on it or I can call NCU on it or I
can call it RAW.
That covers everything
except full training.
Let's say we run profile
of our profile and that just um
converts to run nysxt
kernel level's
current level super slow.
All right. So when you aggregate across
graphs, it's fast.
This is fine for now. I I think I have
an idea on how to do this. Just measure
only kernel timings. Yeah, that doesn't
do [ __ ] though. That's not enough
profiling.
So, I think that the plan here, right,
is we're going to have
every function and individual kernel
uh will be in this profile kernels which
we'll rename it to like microbench or
whatever
or benchmark
and then you'll have two options right
you'll be able to run basic timing or
NSIS or MCU on any any of the functions
or kernels
and then you'll also just be able to run
an overall puffer profile that collects
minimal data during training.
That would be good.
I like that.
Yeah. The problem is that this is just a
big messy monolithic object.
I have no idea what it thinks it's
doing.
makes stupid header files.
I do not want
Oh yeah, let's just add a [ __ ]
260 line header. file. That'll be fun.
What even is this?
Okay, it has the implementations. That's
fine then.
I think the main question is just going
to be like these things.
Yeah, we're going to start letting it
add a bunch of crap here.
Um,
this is not the way it's going to end up
looking,
I don't think.
we did indeed get 10 mil. We have lots
of profiling and clean up to do.
What are tips for making fast sim?
Use C instead of C++. You can make uh
sim just as fast in C++, but it gives
you a whole bunch of tools to make your
code slow without realizing it. So just
write basic logic top to bottom in C.
Don't dynamically allocate memory. You
can allocate all your memory um when you
create the environment and then you
don't need to allocate memory
thereafter. And if you're doing basic
if you're writing basic logic on top of
that like
it's mainly just that CPUs are way
faster than you think and you actually
have to work pretty hard to make them
slow.
It's just that high level languages do a
ton of stupid [ __ ] behind the hood
without telling you.
This is why C is kind of a cheat code.
You just take away all the things that
make your code bad.
man. I just love I love working with
Nvidia libraries. Like
it's like, oh, this is built by people
who know how to code. Cool.
Every time I touch something from
Nvidia, like life is chill. Every time I
touch something from Meta, life sucks.
It's that easy.
I'm pretty sure Nvidia is the only big
tech company where I actually think yeah
they've got some good engineering.
The code is
doesn't matter
what
code is completely
well it that it does kind of suck. I
wish it were open but the thing is like
At least it's good, you know?
I mean, if Torch were a closed horse,
you'd just be [ __ ]
because the code is bad.
So, I think it's generally it's much
easier to write good code open source.
Do you keep listening to music when I'm
kind of tired sometimes? Yeah.
I mean, Nvidia is the only company where
it's like, yeah, they actually have some
pretty good stuff.
Like, if you told me, "Okay, you have to
go replace PyTorch," I'd say like,
"Okay, you know what? Cool. I can do
that." If you told me, "Uh, actually, we
got these new chips. You got to replace
CUDA." I'd be like, "Fuck,
[laughter]
you know.
Perfect.
Beautiful. Look at this.
as simple as it works to a certain
level.
No, it was as simple as the chat being
[ __ ] brain dead and literally
outsourcing all of their thinking to a
language model and like, okay, how do I
do this? Okay, now come up with a plan.
Okay, now implement it. I don't read any
code. Hard. I think I'm very important
because I type word into LLM. Um
like I'm pretty much using it to do
template matching in some sense.
Like I have I went through right and I
came up with the exact way I wanted my
profile to be. I have 10 things that are
like this. Now it's template matching
onto that using my existing code.
So like if we go take a look at this
what this looks like here.
Uh okay this is just this is literally
this block this is not it writing code.
This is it moving code from one file to
another. All right then we'll show you.
Oh also RLD is um reinforcement
learning. I developed the highest
performance reinforcement learning
library and I stream all the development
on it.
So here, look, if it looks like I'm just
doing everything through claw, look,
watch what it's actually doing here
versus the vibe coding [ __ ]
Okay, all this did is this moved over
the forward train block into a header
file. So now it's accessible to the
profile script.
I do wish this thing were faster. That's
my one gripe with it. Um, this is really
bad for
like keeping yourself actively thinking.
But this will get faster over time.
And now you're going to see it's going
to template match. Okay, look. Ah,
that's a lot of code to give it, right?
That's a ton of code to have um claw
writing. Well, what did it actually just
write here?
If we go look at this profile forward
call, so it's template matching onto
this thing that I already checked. And
this thing was actually just template
matching onto
Is it the correctness test? Yeah, any of
these other tests basically because I
already wrote all these profile checks
here. So like this create function.
Look, there's a strct, there's the
create function. It allocates all the
buffers, right? It's a free function,
there's the run function. Like, this is
literally just template map onto this.
And this is basically this is my code.
It calls to my code with glue for
allocating data to run the test
standalone. And these are copied over
from the initialization function in
Puffer Lib C++. So, it really has not
written any logic here. All it has done
is it's like cut up different blocks of
my existing code and then pasted them
into an order that matches the template
that we've already defined. You see the
difference between that and me just like
if I just told this come up with a
profiler, it would make a total mess. It
wouldn't come up with this structure. It
would come up with like a really messy
way of doing it.
And the cool thing is I can iterate on
this and like let's say that I come up
with a better way to do profiling,
right? Like let's say that I redesign it
and I come up with a way to make it 25%
shorter. If I were doing this by hand,
it would suck because I would then have
to manually go and refactor everything,
right? But now if I refactor one of
them, I can just say, "Okay, hey Claude,
this is a new template. Uh like update
all the functions to be this way."
So what I'm doing is instead of using it
to outsource all the thinking, I'm using
it to out I'm outsourcing the most
[ __ ] part of my job, which is
redundantly template matching a bunch of
crap.
And I can see it's messed up the call
arguments here.
It's not for the data. Nice.
Cool.
I'll see if this gets us training.
I think this has commented the backward
pass.
Yeah, this is going to be way too long
of a test.
There we go.
Now we have our nice kernels.
confused. Did we get um Oh, no. We do
have the background.
Cool.
This is good.
This is the same as I have in my uh my
main script. I just didn't know you
could filter by it
See, it just tried to do something that
was completely stupid.
That would have introduced like a
critical
uh timing mismatch.
Okay. So now we have let's say
ranges
Oops.
Got to go pay your tax.
It's actually quite nice that it works
like this.
Oh, did you use the wrong one?
Wait.
I think we'll get like the
we'll get the end to end first and then
we'll start cleaning it.
We also need the end profile.
Why is it not capturing any ranges? Uh,
I'm doing some profiling. That's why
like I'm just I'm not editing the
kernels at this point. I'm just trying
to get us like way better insights and
profiling on everything. It's kind of a
mess, so I'm trying to clean it up.
I think that the script is stupid
anyways,
but hang on. So, we're going to have
Yeah, those don't need to run with at
all.
So, NSIS will just run on these
only cap the first window.
Yeah, that doesn't help them.
I don't know why it's like it's very
funny the number of like just stupid
errors it makes.
If you use it just for template matching
in docs, it's great.
Why does the audio seem low? because I'm
like sliding down in this chair. Um,
thinking about this here
would be better.
Oops.
whatever. Close enough.
Okay.
I would think that it's I don't think
it's including the first range.
Then we can double check very easily if
that's the case.
Fine.
Scrap.
[snorts]
Yeah, that's useless.
Let's see if it is actually corrected.
It's only capturing the first region.
Okay. Okay. So, it is actually doing
Yes.
Yeah, there's a way easier way to do
this.
We don't have this garbage garbage
confusing script. That's better anyways.
And now the shell script gets to be
really freaking simple
there.
And this one takes forever. So, we'll
add like a timeout or something to this.
Okay, this is almost everything we want,
right? Almost.
almost everything.
Then we'll add the environments to it
and we'll be good.
And then this is pretty much everything
we needed for profiling. We got to add
the end in. We got to add the ends. Um
but then pretty much we just get to
clean from here.
If this looks good, I'm just going to
grab some more tea and uh we will
continue. Oh yeah, look. Look at that.
Yeah.
Super nice.
How many monitors? Two. I've got a 27 in
uh horizontal in front of me, like two
feet in front of me, and then I've got a
27 inch vertical to the side for this
stream.
When I was younger, I used to do um two
verticals,
but it's really not needed.
I'll let it go do that. I'm a restroom
real quick and grab myself some tea.
And then we will um we'll add the end of
profiler. And then that's pretty much
all of our profiling that we need.
Okay, let's add the graph timing.
And then um
it looks like we've got 80 mil SPS
forward pass.
100 bill SPS in inference is probably
doable with better kernels.
we're going to have to add the um You
can call the environment timings in
It's a little annoying because um
you know the forward passes.
Oh no, wait. I think the graphs are
consistent. We might be able to just do
it graphed.
What the heck is this?
I'm trying to think how we do this
cleaner.
I guess now it's time to just like start
looking through Puffer C++. Plus, plus
I think that this is
Yeah, we're probably losing perk here.
What we'll do is we'll end up adding um
that script to um puffer commands.
Do you consume content? Movies? Mostly
games. Some game related content. I
don't watch TV or movies almost ever.
I'm actually very unfocused today. Um,
I'm pretty tired, so I'm probably going
to call it an early day today and chill
for a bit.
But I'd like to at least have some
progress on um
the one actual like set of decisions I
want to make essentially is there's a
little bit of restructuring that we need
to do with the main code because these
tests are just a mess, right? These are
super bloated and um the more you're
repeating stuff across your test code
and your main code, the more likely it
is stuff gets out of sync and the tests
are wrong. And that's really bad.
Let's see this.
Okay, this is my code.
Yeah, literally just copied my code.
Cool.
See, this is like something it should
have even seen though because I
literally had this exact thing done in
my code. So, it actually failed to even
fuzzy template match here.
But I think with this it'll have it.
Let's see.
most complicated. will be able to solve.
Most complicated, no idea. That's too
far out for me to tell.
I think it's very likely though that
um we just continue to expand the
company to whatever commercial
applications in the short term and then
in about a year, year and a half once we
have maybe puffer five, probably by
puffer five, um maybe a little bit more
after that, we'll see. uh we should be
able to start making this stuff
generally useful across scientific
simulation.
I think um you know biological sim for
medicine and uh material science
simulation are two of the ones that two
of the areas that interest me the most
for this
And now we should be able to do MS speed
timings,
No, Puffer 5 is actually not going to be
targeting any perf increases whatsoever.
So, if we happen to get some uh if we
happen to get perf increases for Puffer
5, that's cool. But um Puffer 5 is going
to be a purely algorithmic update.
So we will it's instead of increasing
the SPS we will uh we will instead make
changes that decrease the wall clock
solve time of um various hard
environments.
More sample efficient.
Um,
yes. But when you put it that way, the
vast majority of oh, sample efficiency
lit is just crap.
So, what we're going to do is not going
to look like the vast majority of the
lit out there
like, oh, off policy is more sample
efficient. No, it's just bad.
What we're going to do, it's going to
look very different. I have some plans.
Genesis sim for RL.
Oh. Um, like massively bloated and kind
of dumb.
No, you you train on actual Sims.
I mean, look, if they go and decide to
spend like a [ __ ] ton of money, then
yeah, they'll probably get something.
Um, but it's not going to even remotely
work on the problems that we care about,
and it's going to be very flashy. But I
think ultimately what I'm doing here is
going to be more important.
isn't faster.
Genesis is ridiculously slow.
Oh, wait. Genesis sim. Oh, okay. I
confused it with um I was thinking of
Genie. My bad. Uh Genesis is
uh from what I heard last time was
fraud.
their uh their benchmarks that they
released were just [ __ ]
And um you know a couple roboticists
that I know who I trust said that they
essentially it was all smoke and
mirrors.
So my earlier comment was addressed to
Genie which is like the what if we just
learn all the environments thing. Um,
Genesis is supposed to be a faster Isaac
or Manny skill or whatever faster
physics sim, but from what I see, they
just lied on their benchmarks. So, me
So, this is essentially this is a 3x
improvement to breakout speed, but it's
actually it's much more significant than
that because it changes the shape of the
um of efficient configurations.
It's sort of a complicated concept. I'll
do a way better job explaining it when
I'm fresh, but for now, I just got to
get some profiles cranked out.
Why Vim? Why not?
[ __ ]
Uh, okay. I see why it's doing this.
Yeah, that's annoying, but fine.
and then this will bind and then this
will go into the Python most likely
shapes. No, I don't mean mountain
shapes.
essentially it's puffer is going to be
efficient for a wide range of
configurations where it would not have
been efficient from before. So, like,
you know, maybe breakout's 3x faster on
the current settings, right? But then
maybe there's some experiment settings
where it would have been 50,000 steps
per second where now it's going to be
like 2 million
Yes, but it's actually in practice it's
like three it's going to be much more
than 3x on sweeps.
Because the thing is like for small
models it's actually going to be worst
case 3x faster.
You know it could very well be that for
the majority of our experiments it's 10x
faster.
I have to actually like do the uh I have
to get the exact numbers for this
though.
not read
and comm. Do you trust code to not read
and commit? No, of course not.
Sometimes it's like really really really
stupid.
Um,
this is why you see like the when you
see me using it to write huge chunks of
code. I'm not using it to think. I'm
using it for template matching.
Yeah, we no longer need this.
Actually could get shorter, which is
nice.
Perfect.
Very very low overhead.
Oh, you know what? It's This thing
doesn't terminate cleanly.
There we are.
Try this now.
All right, I got to go take a uh I got
to go take a break to go cook some eggs
in a bit.
No reports were generated.
Do that. That's not going to help
though.
I'm trying to think why wouldn't
would it not do
Oh.
Huh?
What's happening with this? Hey, Peru,
welcome.
I was looking over um some stuff in your
repo this morning.
Found a couple other things I want to
integrate, though I've mostly been
working on profiling today.
multi- threading for the GPU. I don't
know what you mean for the GPU batches
like
you use
you have it's not multi-threading right
it's it's CUDA streams
so each there is a manager right um that
is responsible for queuing up
asynchronous transfers on different CUDA
streams
The memory transfers are asynchronous.
So why would that help?
scheduled it ends up blocking the
thread.
Mem copy async
ends up blocking the thread like how
single do because you have multiple
buffers.
You have multiple buffers and the
transfers happen out of order.
talking about the GPU ops.
I don't know what you mean by the GPU
ops.
Like there aren't any GPU operations
happening in the environment.
What am I looking at?
Forward pass.
Oh, are you trying to cue
Are you like queueing both buff buffers
worth of forward passes?
doesn't that defeat the point of doing
this? No, it's We have nway buffering
already, man. But like
it's sequential over N is the whole
point.
if you just launch them all at the same
time. Like the idea is that that is
worse
because what's going to happen if you do
that is yeah, you're going to get all
the GPU work done faster. Um, but it's
going to take long like overall, but
it's going to take longer to queue up
the CPU environment work.
And then those are all going to be done
at roughly the same time as well. like
you're not going to actually get the
environment data back in this sort of
ring buffer style
like what you want is for the CPU work
to be in the background
CPU and threads
smaller GPU four to eight there
shouldn't be four to eight GPU batches
that's a lot.
Most ms are going to have two. Slow M or
really high bandwidth M would have four
or three
because you'd always rather queue up a
bigger batch to the forward pass
anyways.
shows the speed.
Well, but this is the speed versus
versus what the original implementation
because yes, it'll be faster than the
original like multipprocessing or
whatever.
curve shapes up
versus eight batches
that
we're going to I'm going to want to
replicate this on like the branch that I
have because we have a lot less latency
overall here and imaging see three
thread scheding.
Lots of GPU ops.
Yeah, I can see lots of GPU ops with a
ton of launch overhead.
Um,
other threads are waiting for the GPU
copies.
See, this is suspicious to me because
like
this is what you're telling me here. 10
kernels for the entire forecast.
Uh it has to be more than 10 kernels for
the new architecture because you're
benefiting from the monolithic LSTM.
The new architecture has to be more than
10 kernels. But I've gotten it down so
that it's only matt moles and gates.
That's the whole for pass. There's
nothing else.
So like what you're telling me. Okay.
You have this buffer. Oops.
So you have all your environments and
they're like split up into buffers like
this, right? Um and then the GPU is
iterating over those. So what we do
right now is we grab this one and then
we grab this one and then we grab this
one. And you know once this is processed
this now can go to like CPU
and then this is like MTEP
step
and then this is like no GPU
and then you get it back here for your
next iteration.
Right. So, like you do this one, then
you do this one, then you do this one.
Um, the thing I don't understand is
you're saying, well, what if we do all
three of these at the same time, right?
If we cue these all async at the same
time. And what'll happen is if you do
that is it'll take longer for the data
to get to CPU here, it'll take longer.
So then this step will be faster. But
then by like when you try to do the next
step this data is not going to be ready
in time and you should block there.
Of course they don't. It's impossible to
saturate the GPU with batches this
small.
I mean not batches this small. networks
this small and networks this small and
this few amps,
right?
Well, you wait for batch one to finish.
Batch two can schedule more work.
Um, so once you have so this copy here,
this is async.
This is async this op here. So as soon
as you as soon as you send uh memcopy
async here then this can already start
processing the second block.
The last step in your block is not async
though.
What last step? The GPU forward passes.
because
the the GPU forward pass has to block
because you want to get the first batch
of data as quickly as possible,
right? You don't want to you don't want
to make all three forward pass slightly
faster, right? You want to get the first
one as fast as possible so that you can
trig you can queue up this async copy so
that it can start doing the end step
because what you want right is you want
this overhead you want this MTEP to be
done processing by the time you do this
and loop back around.
Bit more complicated. I mean there are
like there are alternative designs I
suppose we could come up with, right?
Like technically, yes, we could just
make it eager on the blocks, right? So
we could make it that the blocks just
all get queued up. As soon as they
finish, they finish. And as soon as one
is ready, then you process it.
You literally end up with a variable
number of buffers because you could
finish the entire segment for this guy.
That has a pretty big speed up. Really?
How?
Like, how on earth does that have a good
speed up?
Yeah, it's a pain in the ass. I just go
and I made this stuff like 3x faster in
the last two months and then oh, global
hardware gets to be three times
expensive.
Dude, this is so weird to me because
you've literally now you split up the
batch. So now your forward passes are on
these tiny little batches that are
completely inefficient for the GPU.
The batch size. The batch size is
definitely not large enough. Or wait,
did you increase the bat size? Wait,
wait. Did you increase the number of M's
for this test?
Nope. Okay.
8192 is valid, but you're definitely not
saturating at 1,00 m
Look, if this architecture is actually
faster, I'd be more h more than happy to
have this in place. I just want to make
sure it actually is going to be. Um
because getting the it took me like
several days of work to get the uh the
current one to be stable. Um the
threading like the threaded backend code
is such a pain in the ass to get to be
nice.
I understand. Okay. So I mean in that
case then what we can do right is if you
have a working backend for this let me
clean up puffer 4 a bit and we can just
match interfaces and we can test them
right
because then we can just bind yours to
our we can bind yours to my profiler
and a puffer and we can compare
because I'm I'm pretty suspicious of the
design of this but if it works it works
cuda caching allocator
out versus fuse, no tensor. Okay. So, I
I will also like I'll acknowledge, okay,
you know, if this thing requires you to
have uh everything more static, that's
fine. I should be doing that anyways.
So, you know, we can say that we'll also
port those optimizations to Puffer
before we try it. That said, I think my
forward pass is more efficient than
yours is. Um because I have
uh I have the
I have the the architecture right I have
the uh mining architecture which is just
matt moles and one custom gate kernel
and I also have it cudigraphed
so I think we have 50 microsconds per
forward pass right now it's 50
microsconds for a forward pass and that
is like the four layer architecture
um with a batch size the 4096.
The one thing that I didn't fuse yet, I
just saw that you found the uh the torch
function for fused gello. I got to go
steal the fuse gelloo for the encoder
layer. I already took your um your fused
uh value function and the logics. I took
that. Uh I adapted the sample logics
code. That was really useful.
Uh, anything else?
I think those were the main two things I
did the other day from your stuff.
Okay. But like we also have to test this
then with a variety of end latencies,
right? Because like the whole point of
the entire point of doing the buffering
is that you have end latency on CPU,
right?
eat. Okay, I got to take a quick break.
I am being called. I will be back in a
few and um we'll continue on this. If
you're still here, we can chat about
this. If not, then we will chat once I
have things cleaned up and we can
actually test your stuff effectively. Uh
thank you though for the
uh for the link to that codebase. Like
there have been several things in there
that have been useful for Optim. I'll be
back.
50 micros can be paralyzed.
Could
I see that being a case?
How surprised would I be?
You know what, Peru? You're probably
right that you can paralyze the forward
pass.
I
believe you that you can paralyze
the forward pass. Um
what I don't understand is how you do
I think you're mostly bound by the um
the host device transfer overhead,
right?
which presumably gets worse in smaller
blocks.
So in my mind, I thought you would like
to have like two buffers.
Can help with the What do you mean can
help with the multi-threading though?
Is there actually overhead time to async
transfers? Like they shouldn't block.
I would think those should be immediate.
No, we do have n buffers and we we each
buffer has its own stream.
We have n buffers. Each has its own
stream.
So yeah, the async copies are from the
same thread, but they're all async.
Try to say right now, thread Q up GPUs
copies. My thread cues up GPU copies.
But then why does the GPU copy so why
does the async GPU copy operation like
why does that need to be cued if it's
instantaneous
right none of these should be blocking
transfers
what do you mean the GPU ops the forward
pass is blocking
All right.
Ford call will wait for other batches to
arrive. Yes.
But the trade-off here is if you if you
do the forward calls out of order,
if you do the forward calls out of
order, you're going to queue up the
memory transfers back to this CPU out of
order.
Uh you can also do this with or without
threading I would believe.
We will have to test it
ultimately.
without multi thread. I think it's hard
to do the GPU ops without
multi-threading.
See the thing I don't understand here
about this is that like
so if you just do the forward pass time
right our forward pass can run eval at
like 80 million steps per second
and we're mostly what we're getting
bottlenecked by is the um the host
device transfer.
So in my mind, I thought it would be
more important that we have the host
device transfer be done in order so that
you don't have to wait on that, right?
Because what you don't want is you don't
have you don't want to have to wait on
uh host device transfer for the batch of
data that you currently need because
memory bandwidth is being taken up by
another batch that you need later.
That's why I did it roundroin.
So I mean I agree that empirically I
guess we can just test because what
you're doing is you're just doing it
full async with n buffers and I'm doing
it round robin with nb buffers. That's
what it ultimately comes down to.
Most one set is currently being yeah
one set of GPU ops is being scheduled.
Yes, that's how we have it working.
Well, it's not the end ops aren't fully
async in a sense cuz like
the M's are still processed in order on
our back end.
So what we do is we ensure we ensure
that you always process the data that
you're going to need the soonest first.
That's the difference. So by not having
it fully async,
we are ensuring um that the Ms are
actually being computed in the order
that you need them.
Because if you do it fully async, you
can like chew through the entirety of
one block, right? The whole horizon of
one block. And now you're stuck with
like way worse than what we have now,
which is full serial, no buffering,
right?
The extent of that happens in practice,
I don't know.
But basically what we would have to do
um Peru is we'd have to test and I need
to make a little benchmark for this. We
should test your architecture versus my
architecture with um different end
latency and different OB size. Those are
the key factors. Uh end latency, OB
size, and then like network latency.
The horizon does you're correct. The
horizon does parallelize.
I just don't know if it's worth it or
not.
Because like I would think in my
architecture right I know that my
architecture should scale well because
as you scale up the network size in my
architecture right uh you saturate the
GPU and then uh you ensure that the host
device latency is way lower of a deal.
So basically in my roundrobin
architecture, you guarantee that you
never have to wait on host device
transfer because the net will take long
enough.
So I don't know how your architecture
works in that case if it scales nicely.
But I maybe
it could be in the very fast case with
small nets um that your architecture is
better.
Not for G24 because it uses U and 8.
Uh well we'll fix dt type things. Um
that's just interface problem.
It's somewhat annoying because we have
to test it with the network in the loop,
right? Because like I have right now I
have a standalone env test where I get
29 million stat per second vec, but
that's without the env in the loop.
verified end to end training. So that's
good. So then we should be able to bind
this stuff up pretty quick, right? Happy
to collab and bounty. I mean, I can set
you a bounty for this thing. Sure. I'm
happy to pay you if this thing um
actually speeds stuff up cuz this is a
pretty non-trivial piece of work.
I don't normally offer that because um
you know core dev it's all open source
but like know if you're going to come to
me and saying hey I have this awesome
thing and it's going to be faster then
sure
how many SPS is this getting well this
is the annoying thing right like we
can't even give SPS because like it
could be that if I run you know mine
could be faster or his could be faster
if we run the pure end of SPS test but
then it's going to different with the
network in the loop.
And in order to give him a fair test, I
also need to make sure that my net has
like static shapes and everything.
Shouldn't say bounty just yet.
Yeah, it's in a little bit of a tricky
place actually, Peru, because like you
know with the end contributors, I know
that the end work matches um our
professional work. So once people have
built a good env and have done have
gotten RL working on it, I know that
they're good to like do professional
work and that pays quite well. Um it's a
little difficult with the core
contributions because like you know
you're doing work that's very technical
that very few of the contributors can
deal with. Um so that stuff is awesome
but then like can I offer you
professional work off of that on like a
client thing? I don't know because it's
kind of different work, right? So, I can
definitely pay you something for um like
speed ups if you'd like to do stuff that
way.
I'm happy to do that. I'd like just I'll
set some I'll set something up on like
whatever stable puffer 4 is.
Sure. Sounds good. Now, I will say um
let's say that yours does work and we
want to like add it as our main VEC back
end because it's just better across the
board. I'm probably going to want to
have it ported into minimal C instead of
having like a bunch of C++ locking
shenanigans. I have no idea how hard
that is, but it would be nicer to have
it that way. Um, but we can figure that
out later. I mean, like I can even do
that. Like it'll worth it'll be worth me
doing that um if it's actually faster
because Envc is very very important
actually. You know, here's one other
thing that you can think about. Um, so
right now we have stuff done in blocks.
You can do stuff fully fully
asynchronous across all the ends and not
even have any blocks.
Uh the issue with that is that you end
up with a bunch of strided copies
which
I don't think that there is a efficient
way to do that
forces certain style of thinking. Yeah,
except with dealing lichrch. Well, the
lib torch templates just suck is the
thing, right?
But yeah, I really do like just my
minimal C.
It really really pains me to have be
doing all this like row C++ I'm doing
now.
C force me to change my thinking style.
Well, it's just it's very minimal.
It's a lot easier to know where all your
compute overhead is going in C. C++ just
gives you way too many ways to shoot
yourself in the feet.
Okay,
pro or max.
I use the API, dude.
Right. So, okay, where we were before
this um requires a PhD I think. So, I
won't bother with that. So,
there is some stuff that can be cut out
of train. There are a bunch of redundant
things. Um, I will say the problem with
the training right now, there are all
these fancy indexing ops that are
because of the algorithm we're using
that may or may not disappear in the
next version. Anyways, so I don't want
to go too hard onto the training because
uh other except for like generic
optimizations, maybe you can queue up
stuff more parallel with Muan or
whatever. But um any of the indexing
stuff like that might just go away in
the next version.
How much was the bill for that claude
stream? Which one?
I think total it's been like three 400
bucks so far in credits.
We're going to pixel pixel pixel
platformer. That's great. Yeah, we can
grab this. See you around. Thanks, Peru.
Okay. Um, let's figure out what the heck
happened here.
how to make RL more sample efficient.
Uh we have some well I think if you just
think more sample efficient as a general
concept
you're probably not thinking clearly
about the problem. Um
RL is actually plenty sample efficient
for a number of problems. There are
classes of problems where it is
exponentially bad and
but you can't just think oh sample
efficiency in general for that.
We have a couple active projects and
we're going to start another one or two
when we do um puffer five on that. We
have some ideas.
We'll be all screamed here
It's so [ __ ] stupid. It just missed
this.
Nice job, Claude.
There we go,
dummy.
Yeah, I think what we're going to do
today, I'm going to do like another
hour, hour, 20 minutes. We'll do like
six hour stream today and then I'll get
some rest.
I mean, really the main thing I want is
I just want to have a a good start on
the profiling today.
Do you read books? Uh, audio books.
Yeah, I go through it depends what I'm
doing because I mostly listen to them
while I'm exercising.
If I'm doing like a endurance training
block or whatever,
um, then I go through a huge huge number
of books.
Lately, I've been playing some games,
but that kind of depends on um time of
year and what else I'm doing.
It's good at the moment because like
I've been doing more of these long
streams where I'm just banging my head
against Cuda and that makes me very
tired. So, it's good to have some stuff
to chill with. Recommendations. Books.
Yeah. Find book. I don't read serious
books, man. I mostly just read a ton of
um I treat like reading as a creative
inspiration.
Um and I used to do a lot of creative
writing when I was younger. So, I read
mostly uh a little bit of sci-fi and
then mostly fantasy.
Okay, so this takes way too long. Um,
we're probably capturing too much crap,
but maybe this gives us a proper profile
now
time. Have not read that. What's good in
those genres? Well, sci-fi the best. My
favorite is the Culture series. Um,
fantasy. I like uh was it Aragon? That
series. Um, Furies of Calderon. Very
good. Um,
I went through most of the Dresden files
and then stopped. It was kind of okay
and then went downhill.
Um, some of that's fun, some is just
kind of dumb and corny.
Uh, what else? I did what? Go through
the Lord of the Rings. I actually was
not that impressed by that.
What else? So many series.
At least a few other series I've gone
through.
Can't think of them off the top of my
head.
Culture. Yeah, culture is really great.
Culture is really great.
I find it very difficult to read most
sci-fi because like
most writers are just so non-technical.
They have just such a stupid vision of
tech. It's just unbearable. Culture is
pretty good.
I actually think Game of Thrones is
awful.
I think it's generally terrible writing.
It was written to be a TV series.
It's like super ADHD. just cut around to
a million different scenes like oh build
suspense who's going to die what's going
to happen it's like it was made to be a
TV series and it made a good TV series
with high budget acting and effects um
not good writing though
Greg Egan
no I have not
what is that
oh diaspor Bro, I think I've been
recommended this.
I [sighs] got to see that at some point.
I'm reading um I started reading the
Stormlight Archives.
I downloaded the first book of that and
it was a a 55h hour audio book. I was
like, "Oh, okay.
This decent enough so far.
But I haven't had as much reading time
lately. Um because I haven't really been
doing my endurance running. I've kind of
just been doing some hard 5ks.
PhD stressful?
Yes, but probably not in the way that
you expect. I generally don't recommend
people do a PhD unless they say, "Oh,
yeah. I really want to do a PhD. I know
that I want to do this. It's like then
go for it, right? Um, but I don't ever
try to convince people to do a PhD.
Use of weapons is
incredibly [ __ ] up, but has one of my
favorite I think the opening of that
book has one of my favorite scenes in
all of writing.
Well, I'm not doing the oh, you're out
of tokens, wait like six hours [ __ ]
right?
the like, "Oh, I'm here to kill you."
scene.
It struck me as very self-aware.
Um,
it struck me as very self-aware in some
sense,
you know, because Ian has like um
I always say like the ideal future is
something like the culture but a little
less calming and a little less horny.
But um it's funny because he's like very
aware
of himself sometimes.
PhD is obsolete
not having done it. Well, I mean it's
not really obsolete to go spend 5 years
thinking about a particular problem,
right, that is um important but is
currently not really getting any
attention and is difficult to
investigate in a different capacity.
Actually, academia being old, that's not
actually the correct
So the problem with academia is it's
somewhat myopic and that academia has a
playbook just like industry has a
playbook. Academia has a playbook and
that playbook is actually good for
solving different problems than you will
see solved in industry. It is effective
in certain cases but it's very limiting
and quite often uh solving the most
interesting problems requires you to go
outside of either established playbook.
And this is where academia will fight
you. It's not a place for any type of
new ideas. It's a place for a specific
type of new idea. Just like industry is
a place for a specific type of new idea,
which is why I've gotten so much done on
my own here with Puffer in the last two
years.
I no longer have the constraints of
either.
So, I mean, you can criticize academia,
and I do plenty, but at least make the
right criticisms of it.
Most papers are incremental.
No, most papers are wrong.
The problem is not that most papers are
incremental.
It's that most papers are wrong.
series is good. I actually I was given
for Christmas. I was given um
the book of his drawings.
Now he has all these sketches uh
unpolished sketches has been compiled
into a book.
Productive work is incremental paper
incremental and wrong. But the thing is,
if the papers were incremental and
correct, if you were to stack that
number of incremental improvements,
you'd actually very quickly make
progress.
The problem is that most papers are
wrong.
Clip this kale that. See, that's also
not
you're correct at the high level, but
you're very very wrong about the actual
like the actual problems with academia
and why
stuff is a mess.
Like I have a very very precise view on
this now um from my time there, right?
like actually you need more like you
know clip this kale all that you need
more unsexy
uh heavily experimentally validated
things. The problem with academia is
they produce these big sexy methods that
have all this math and all this fancy
stuff that works on one problem is not
validated extensively and just ends up
being useless because you can't make it
work anywhere else and actually it turns
out the idea was wrong and J they just
optimized this more than they optimize
the baseline. That's the problem with
academia. And then if you do publish
something that is a legitimate
improvement across the board but isn't
sexy, uh the reviewers will fight you on
that and it's very difficult to get that
type of work out. So a lot of the stuff
I've done with Puffer is very
engineering heavy. We have a small set
of method changes that are not
particularly sexy, but we have validated
extensively and as a result we're able
to train tasks in seconds that would
have taken days with other libraries,
other methods and so on and so forth.
And we now are actually using RL
commercially successfully as well and
doing it without a huge number of
resources without funding.
So
there are many many problems with what
was being done but not the particular
ones you're pointing out.
All right, here we are. Look at this.
This is nice.
Okay. So, this is not going to actually
copy.
Yeah. So, this is wrong. That's fine.
higher than incremental improvements.
see an incremental improvement that is a
few percent that is a simple thing that
does not add complexity that is a few
percent across the board um that
actually works is act that's a great
contribution.
The problem with incremental work is it
also often adds complexity and is like
either wrong a good chunk of the time or
wrong like all of the time
purely about engineering. So no, no,
that's not correct.
Our algorithm is fundamentally better
than the base PO we started with.
We have a set of modifications to it
that make um Puffer 3, mostly off of
algorithmic changes, is about 3x better
than puffer 2.
We also have our own hyperparameter
tuning algorithm and we've published
several blogs about it.
Why not blog? I do blog.
If you change one line of code, why is
it worth the paper?
Because if you change one line of code
and you're going to say that this gives
a 5% improvement,
you need to have experiments on
everything. And if it is 5% like 90% of
the time but then it's worse 10% of the
time we need to understand why
why should I spend hours okay I mean
maybe this is easier for you to know to
understand with optimizers right
so if there's a drop if there's an
optimizer that is a drop in 5% better
across the board that is a major major
contribution
No, I haven't read his blog. I have his
hardware though.
How much SPF did we start with? Well,
when like when I started puffer like a
few thousand
and now we're to 10 million.
Oh yeah, the publishing game is stupid
for sure.
I mean, you can say that, but basically
the only way that I'm able to do the
stuff that I do is because I spend over
a decade in academia.
And I have a pretty good understanding
of the literature as a whole, as well as
the jankiness of various sections of it,
and what ideas out there are actually
likely to be useful that just have not
been validated with good enough
engineering versus what stuff is
completely made up.
Like it would be very very difficult to
do puffer without that experience,
right? Otherwise I would have just done
it out of undergrad.
in the same repo.
Oh, you don't want that, man. That's
what happens with robotics.
All right, they work on the same repo.
If you've ever want to see if you ever
want to see generational trauma in a
code repo, go check out like some of the
um motion imitation work with robotics.
It's actually just generations of PhD
students wrapping each other's god
awful, unreadable, super slow code until
nobody knows what the [ __ ] is happening
anymore.
If you want to get go get Torvolts for
it, sure. They're very very few people
who can actually do that effectively.
And um
yeah, it's just
you're not going to change [ __ ] by
changing processes.
I guess this is better though. So, we'll
take this
Okay, then we have
look what do we have out of this, right?
We have timings for
um all tagged regions.
Pretty low overhead timings actually for
all tagged regions.
Isn't there a thing like isn't lean like
literally not expressive enough? Isn't
there a thing with that?
Okay.
Where do we go from here? We have
I'm getting to be pretty tired here.
Let me think what else we can do today.
or at least what is next to be done on
the list.
Like we have our basic end profiling set
up.
Yeah. So, we have 90 um 90
micros
on roll out actually, not 60.
Interesting.
We got
I mean, I think it's just a big cleanup
after this
will work and what don't. I know for
pretty much every every major area of
RL.
Uh, I generally know like what is useful
from there versus what was fluff,
including when like, oh yeah, there are
like six deep mind papers in this area
and actually it still doesn't work.
There are areas like that
where like, hey, there's this area where
like everything doesn't work except this
one thing that actually does work uh but
is underused because of this, that, and
the other that I'm going to use, you
know, next year for the next update or
whatever.
I think we want to let let's just make
the last thing I do today. Let's get um
I think I can probably get some regions
of the code just cleaned up a little bit
without doing dumb stuff with Claude,
right?
Can you write about it to save people
time? I can do even better. I can take
that and I can put it into a
reinforcement learning library that's
fast and actually works.
This is literally um 10,000 times the
speed of um clean RL on on their version
of Breakout for reference.
It's a thousand. What is it? Is it 100x?
I think 100x faster than the so-called
higherf libraries that are out there.
Hey
You grew smarter.
I got better at stuff. I got more
effective for sure.
Oh, you're going to need a [ __ ] ton of
compute to beat go.
I mean, they use search in that problem,
dude.
Chess was done in 1995. Isn't it easy?
Wasn't done in 1995 with search free RL.
I mean by that logic sure I can also
write a I can write a breakout solving
agent script in like 10 minutes or less
but that's missing the point.
I'm just going to do a little bit of
like casual clean up here for a bit and
then I'm going to chill for the rest of
the day. I think that's what we're going
to do.
Let's get this to look something
reasonable.
Which fields enable you to write popper
lib?
Um well it depends what chunk of it,
right? So hang on.
That's fine. I don't know if I like it
this way actually, but we'll start with
it here. This be fine.
Um, so
a lot of the like multi- aent RL
infrastructure work I did was the core
of that uh was the core of it
originally.
Um,
experience with on versus off Paul,
right? And that gap led me to go with on
Paul, which was a very good decision.
The uh hyperparameter tuning lip
familiarity helped me with protein.
Uh basically the the aggregate
experience with fancy RL as a whole led
me Oh, and actually
There are a few specific papers that
helped me with 30 as well. And it's less
so like oh I read this paper as much as
it was like me being able to know okay
that's actually probably usable whereas
all these other 20 ideas are not.
I guess the way that you're putting it
is like you develop an like a good model
where you can quickly assess what is the
probability that this thing is actually
usable versus complete [ __ ]
Yeah. I don't know if I actually I
wouldn't actually write the code this
way normally.
Yeah, that actually is kind of gross,
isn't it?
Let me uh let me see what this does if I
run it.
This is good for profiling. I don't know
if it's good for much else.
We'll probably end up undoing that. I
think I'm just about out of energy for
today, though. Let me see if I didn't
This still works.
That does still work.
And mill
I got to do this brush and I'm tired.
I got to do this brush. Let's go. just
add uh everything up into the let's
commit everything up basically.
Yeah, I'm just like I did not get good
rest yesterday from the celebrations.
Um, but here's what we're going to do,
right? So, we have the initial profiling
today, which is about as much as I could
have asked for. All
We have a reasonable way of integrating
NSIS for everything.
Uh, and now I mostly just need to figure
out how we just clean everything up so
that we cannot have everything be stupid
and redundant,
which I need to do that fresh because if
I do it now, I'll let Claude do it. And
like, as you just saw, that was a total
mess. So, I'm going to have to undo some
of that stuff. Um,
so I at least need to be able to like be
uh
yeah, I need to be on point for that
stuff. So, I think I'm just going to go
chill. I'm going to enjoy the rest of my
afternoon. I got a couple messages to
answer as well, so I'll do that. Uh,
tomorrow I probably have to do some
client work off stream, but then the
goal will be that I will be rested and
then we will start uh major cleanup on
Saturday. And the goal is by the end of
day Saturday that we actually have
something that's like, you know,
reasonably
okay quality for uh initial puffer 4.
Probably not tomorrow. It depends. I
think I got to do some client work. So
I'll see you all around. Um if you're
interested in my work generally, please
do feed the puff or star on GitHub. It
really helps me out. It's free. You can
join Discord if you want to get involved
with dev. You can follow me on extra